-Welcome back, everybody!
I'm here with Pete Davidson now!
-Thank you.
-We are both
fans of the New York Knicks,
and because
they just won their
first round playoff series,
I thought it'd be fun.
That's right.
I thought it'd be fun
to challenge you
to a Random Object shootout.
Okay, now here's how this works.
We're going to take turns
trying to shoot random objects
into that hoop.
If you make it in,
you get a point.
The objects that
we're shooting tonight are...
a Pete Davidson
action figure.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's what --
-We invented for you.
-Thank you.
-You really wore
this outfit once.
-I did.
-Yes, you did.
This is a Yankees batting helmet
filled with ice cream sundae.
It's a giant version.
-Very good.
-Yes.
This is a New York Rangers
hockey stick.
-Alright.
-This is a New York
pizza pie in the box.
And last worth, five points,
a bowl of New York
lottery balls.
-Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Pete, since I'm the host,
I will go first.
I just saw this
for the first time.
I was going to say since
you're the guest.
-No, you can go first.
-Wow.
Thank you so much.
Alright, I'll go first.
Alright, we can both stay here
and we'll shoot from here.
-We both stay here, okay.
-Alright, ready?
-Yeah, I didn't come
to rehearsal, so...
-No, I understand.
Me neither.
-Yeah.
-Alright. Okay, here we go.
Maybe I'll do underhand?
-Yeah, sure.
Alright, this is --
this is
the Pete Davidson
action figure.
Here we go.
By Mattel.
Oh, sorry.
[ Audience "oohs" ]
-Wait.
No, Pete. You can't --
[ Cheers and applause ]
No!
What, what, what, what!
[ Laughs ]
Dude, that was some stuff.
You don't -- leave him there.
Leave him there.
-That hurt.
-Leave him there.
That hurts.
That, yeah. That wasn't cool.
-That hurt. That hurt.
That was good.
-Yeah.
-Wow.
That was a good dunk.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
This one, the ice cream sundae.
-Okay.
[ Cheering ]
-Oh.
-[ Blows raspberry ]
Sorry, sir.
Yeah, underhand might be
the way to go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dude, how are you good at this?
How are you good at this?
We didn't practice this.
Oh, my God.
-[ Laughs ]
Alright, bud.
Here we go.
-Oh.
-I think that's the closest
you're going to get to that.
-I mean...
-Yeah, I didn't know --
Yeah.
-It was like --
-Boom, you got to...
-A vibe.
-Alright, fine.
So he's human.
So he's human, okay?
-Okay.
Fine. Yeah.
Alright, this is --
This is a pizza.
You can do it any
way you want.
-Okay.
-It looks good, though.
-Yeah, it does.
Yeah.
-Alright.
-It's been here a while.
-Yeah, it's a couple
of days old.
-Yeah.
You can throw like this?
Do you discus it?
Do you spin it around
and toss?
-I think it's like a...
-Is it a toss up?
-I think it's like that.
-Should I take it
out of the box?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
In New York City,
you fold the pizza.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's pretty good, actually.
Pretty good.
That's the way to do it.
-Not bad.
-I almost don't want
to chuck this.
[ Audience "Ohs" ]
-What are you doing?
What are you doing?
How are you remotely --
This is insane.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright.
Pete, Pete, Pete.
I know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're yelling
Pete, Pete, Pete.
Alright. I don't know
why I'm trying this.
-This is like a weird,
wet dream I'm having.
[ Laughter ]
It's time for the money ball,
the bowl of New York
lottery balls.
Remember,
this is worth five points.
[ Laughs ] What am I
talking about?
That's been --
this has been amazing.
Thank you.
What an appearance.
Oh, my gosh.
All right, here we go.
Come on.
Five points.
It just looks good.
Just do it for fun.
Here he goes right there.
Star of "Bupkis,"
Pete Davidson
right here,
ladies and gentlemen.
Yeah, that's it!
You did it.
The winner, the champion,
Pete Davidson.
"Bupkis" premieres next Thursday
on Peacock.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
How are you?
Dude, how are you doing?